hello everybody and welcome to my
variables in Python 3 tutorial video in
this video I will teach you guys about
and girls about variables which you will
quickly find yourself using extremely
frequently pretty much in every single
program you ever write variables act as
a placeholder for whatever you place in
them and it can be changed so they are
as you guessed variable so let's go
ahead and show some examples of these
variable variables so for starters let's
say we just have example var so what
this is and how you define a variable in
Python is you just type it out so
variables can have all kinds of fun
stuff in them you can do what's known as
camel casing or you can use a lot of
people will do like example var like
this and a lot of people even capitalize
their variables like this so they use
all caps and underscores honestly at the
end of the day it really doesn't matter
but um like I said a lot of you guys
have teachers or whatever and they get
pretty anal about this kind of stuff so
you know do whatever they say
but I do camel casing pretty much for
everything i camelcase
my variables my functions pretty much
all that stuff so um that is improper by
you know programming standards uh so
take that as you will anyway so example
var is our variable name and then you
just follow it with equals and we're
just going to say example 4 equals 55
for now and then we're going to print
out a example bar so now let's just save
and run that and sure enough it prints
out 55 you can also have example bar
equals 55 plus 32 so you can not only
have example bar equal uh just something
it can actually equal a quick operation
so we'll do this 87 an example of our
can also check this out can contain a
function
so in this case we have a very simple
function oh isn't this interesting
example of our equals
prints oops whoa
imagine neo as you say whoa anyway uh so
we knew that so let's run that and you
can see in the definition it you know
went whoa and we never actually even had
a call example for but if we call
example bar again we get whoa so now um
so you can put functions in there
and you can do uh some some other stuff
too that I'll show you guys in just one
moment called unpacking um try to think
of there's anything else actually I
think I've covered everything I really
want to cover um so let me delete I
delete that and let me show you guys one
last part of variables
that's pretty integral or useful and
that's going to be unpacking so when you
unpack a variable but you can do is you
could say like a common operation would
be like coordinates right so you could
say X comma y equals and then you could
say your coordinates are three five okay
now what that's going to do is it's
going to unpack this Python list into x
and y so what you can do now is we can
do stuff with our new variables and in
this case let's just print them run that
and you can see that it prints X which
is 3 and Y which is 5 pretty neat but
what if you try to do like this so now
you're trying to you've got two
variables but you've got three bits of
data that you're trying to unpack you're
going to get this error too many values
to unpack we'll talk about this again in
a little bit because I will have a bit
of a debugging basics later on but just
take note that it must be equal like you
must unpack the same number of variables
so for now I think that'll cover the
introduction of variables and all that
so if you guys have any questions about
variables feel free to post them below I
do respond to the comments otherwise
hopefully you guys learn something new
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support in the subscriptions and
until next time